generally speaking you never want to be
in a small boat in the middle of the
ocean with two very opinionated airline
pilots particularly if a rain storm is
coming in and one of those pilots is
your mother but this happened to me
recently and it got me thinking besides
bringing back to driving to all kinds of
new levels it reveals something about
commercial pilots that I've always known
they have each other's backs and they
make great teams growing up my brother
and I were always very proud of our
mothers career as a pilot we loved
hearing her wild stories and we always
got a kick out of hearing her voice over
the loudspeaker before landing but for
us flying was a sort of exotic foreign
part of her life especially as I got
older I thought her career has very
little to do with mine but a day on the
boat and other days I realized that
that's not altogether true they're
elements of aviation that a broader
audience can learn from specifically
pilots have unlocked the code to
teamwork at the rest of us need imagine
for a moment the copilot has controls
over the 767 as it approaches Newark and
suddenly the wind changes direction and
the hail is hitting the windshield so
heavily that the flight crew is actually
shouting at each other to get through
the landing checklist on top of all this
it looks like they may need to make a
last-minute switch to a shorter runway
to the outside observer the space seem
like chaos but to everyone involved
everything is as it should be the pilot
the copilot the flight attendants that
the company dispatchers are all working
together like one instrument what would
you do with that kind of teeth think
about that for every flight you've ever
taken for every flight that left San
Francisco Airport this morning one of
thousands of pilots showed up to work
may have never
the copilot before may never meet that
person again but for the next eight or
nine hours well you're in the back
working or watching rom-coms or whatever
we do on airplanes they became a highly
functioning team the kind of team that
deals with last-minute windstorms and
engine failures and landing decisions
what would you do with that kind of team
now I know at this point I may have
totally lost you you may be thinking
flying is way too far out of an analogy
to be relevant to my career its
unionized the promotions are based on
seniority not performance and it's so
dangerous the 180 people in the back of
that plane are way more important than
any spreadsheet that I ever built but
bear with me I used to think that way
too but I think there are elements of
aviation that fuel this kind of
camaraderie that the rest of us can
learn from and before diving into what
those are there's something else that I
should tell you about my mother in 1973
when she applied to American Airlines
she could not imagine doing anything
else her brother was a pilot her father
was a pilot from what I can tell she cut
more high school and she attended to
become a pilot if it's not already here
she is much cooler than I am but there
was one problem American had never hired
a woman before in fact no major airline
had and it turns out that she's quite
stubborn which is unlucky for me and
lucky for her in this situation and she
got hired but when she showed up for
work she sometimes struggled to fit in
literally they had to redesign the
pilot's uniform and of course this
cockpit culture that was very developed
an established had to shift a little bit
with some being more receptive than
others and the reason this is relevant
is because despite all of these seeming
obstacles the camaraderie she had always
associated with flying persisted even
though her flying community had
ballooned from the handful of people at
pompano beach
South Florida Airport to the thousands
of people at any major hub everyone had
each other's back I think that is
extraordinary so today I'd like to
suggest three things that I think create
this environment that maybe we can adapt
in our own the first is simple is
proximity when yahoo decided they no
longer were in allowing people to work
remotely there was a lot of buzz but
behind that decision was a very basic
assumption that to work well people need
to work together they need to see each
other in person frequently and sometimes
without interruption and commercial
aviation takes that to an extreme if you
think about the cockpit you might also
ask when was the last time that you
spent eight or nine hours alone in a
closet-sized room with just your boss
and your direct report with no meal
breaks and certainly no internet surfing
and you just stayed there for a long
time no wonder these people have bonds
and I know that sounds silly but over
the course of the few months that I've
been thinking about this I've had the
chance to ask many of you about your
experiences with camaraderie in the
workplace and a theme emerged often if
work extended late into the night
sometimes appear or a boss would you sit
with you and sometimes they would help
you and sometimes they would do their
own thing but they're just being there
created a sense of motivation that
lasted for years to come proximity the
second idea is a concept there's a
combination of shared expertise with
distinct roles at American every six
months every pilot goes down to Dallas
for intense and rigorous training
simulator training emergency training
you name it and one consequence besides
being relief to all of the passengers is
everyone knows what everyone else knows
everyone shares the latest expertise my
mom has described it as cut from the
same cloth you know what I know
I know what you know and we trust each
other at the same time everyone in the
cockpit has a very distinct role down to
a checklist everyone is distinct and
everyone is necessary just like the
parts of an engine the combination of
these two things means that everyone has
a context and understanding but also a
dependency that creates these
astonishing teams and the third idea is
purpose in the cockpit the purpose is
very clear get your passengers from
point A to point B safely and as quickly
as possible and the process may be
complicated and the roadblocks might be
unexpected but the outcome is clear well
general general McChrystal came to the
GSB earlier this fall he shared an idea
a similar idea called shared
consciousness the role of the manager is
not only to articulate the purpose but
to make sure that everyone gets behind
it purpose I know that the analogy to
flying implies some degree of extreme
extreme danger extreme weather extreme
camaraderie but I think that this
teamwork plays out most authentically in
smaller moments and one of those moments
happened on one of my mother's first
layovers in Chicago you're approaching
the airport and as I mentioned at the
time there were no other female pilots
so a good shorthand for the pilots
lounge was male crew only so in
anticipation of this someone pulled her
aside and said Bonnie just so you know
this is a situation you may want to
steer clear and so she did I mentioned
that she was stubborn but she's also
very polite and she was certainly not
there to create a stir so she was going
to shuffle off so they land and they're
approaching the lounge and she sees it
sure enough it says male crew only but
as they get closer she sees that someone
written something underneath and it now
says milk who only and Bonnie too I'm
sure that she played it cool but this
was obviously very exciting and
triumphant for her but I think it also
signals the astonishing way the
camaraderie is at play at one of the
largest such a large organization so
today I talked about three ideas that I
think create this environment proximity
shared with distinct and purpose so I
asked you if you could capture even a
slice of this camaraderie for yourselves
imagine what we could do thank you